und sie haben es gesehen der saal füllt
sich auch die regierungsbank ist gut
gefüllt denn jetzt kommt es hier zu
einer ersten beratung eines
gesetzentwurfs der schon viel thema war
in der debatte
denn es geht um das bundeswehr
sondervermögen 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen will die bundesregierung
für die bundeswehr ausgeben um sie zu
modernisieren 100 milliarden euro das
ist eine zahl mit elf nullen
das ist eine zahl die auch gebraucht
wird wenn denn die zeitenwende wie von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz angekündigt
wird vollbracht wird denn bislang wurde
viel gespart bei der bundeswehr und es
wurde auch immer wieder gesagt dass eben
da geld fehlt das material fehlt
personal um hier
einsatzfähig zu sein
diese 100 milliarden euro die sollen als
sondervermögen
betitelt werden das heißt dass sie nicht
unter die schuldengrenze fallen unter
die schuldenregelung aber die
bundesregierung möchte auch dieses
sondervermögen ins grundgesetz schreiben
lassen und deswegen braucht es dafür
eine zweidrittelmehrheit hier im
deutschen bundestag das bedeutet dass
auch die union für diese abstimmung
gebraucht wird deswegen ist es hier ein
etwas heikles unterfangen denn bisher
hat die union noch nicht ihre zustimmung
signalisiert sondern hat bestimmte
forderungen an dieses sondervermögen
unter anderem geht es darum
da wie diese 100 milliarden euro
ausgegeben werden wie sie auch
zurückgezahlt werden
das wird jetzt hier in der debatte
wahrscheinlich auch diskutiert werden
und wie zum beispiel auch dass zwei
prozent ziel der nato eingehalten werden
kann das fordert die union hier im
deutschen bundestag
und als erster spricht auch der
bundesfinanzminister christian ellinger
zum sondervermögen bundeswehr
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
völkerrechtswidrige angriff russlands
auf die ukraine hat unzählige
menschliches leid verursacht
er hat die friedens- und stabilitäts
ordnung in europa und auch die wirkung
des völkerrechts zerstört wir sind in
eine neue phase eingetreten es ist eine
zeitenwende wie der bundeskanzler
neulich an dieser stelle gesagt hat
russland darf diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen die ukraine darauf diesen krieg
nicht verlieren und deshalb unternehmen
wir alles dafür
unternehmen wir alles dafür um der
ukraine zur seite zu stehen in der
vergangenheit gab es zeiten da wurde die
deutsche geschichte bemüht für nichtstun
jetzt wissen wir aus der deutschen
geschichte ergibt sich eine
verantwortung dafür dass wir handeln in
deutschland und europa
der angriffskrieg russland verändert
auch die internationale ordnung die
globale governance verändert auch die
sicherheitslage der bundesrepublik
deutschland wie wir erkennen müssen
auch die frage der bündnis und
landesverteidigung spielt heute eine
größere rolle als wir alle wenige jahre
zuvor
geglaubt hätten es geht nicht um eine
militarisierung der deutschen außen- und
sicherheitspolitik aber wir müssen
erkennen dass die bundeswehr nicht in
zustand ist indem sie sein muss
angesichts der veränderten risikoprofils
es geht nicht um eine militarisierung
der außenpolitik aber um eines man muss
kämpfen können um nicht kämpfen zu
müssen und deshalb muss die bundeswehr
ertüchtigt werden
die bundesregierung reagiert auf die
zeitenwende in vielerlei hinsicht und
auch mit dem jetzt hier eingebrachten
sondervermögen und es wären auf die
anforderungen des bundeskanzlers hin
habe ich als fachlich zuständige
minister ein sondervermögen
vorgeschlagen die alternative etwas
steuern zu erhöhen würde nicht nur aus
ordnungspolitischen gründen sondern auch
angesichts der makroökonomischen
situation
gefährlich sein
also haben wir uns für den weg eines
sondervermögens entschieden um 15 jahre
vernachlässigung unserer streitkräfte
schnell zu beenden es ist eine
kraftanstrengung ja dieses
sondervermögen wird mit krediten
finanziert aber in dieser zeit in dieser
lage ist es anders nicht möglich den
realitäten gerecht zu werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
angst dazu entschieden ihnen
vorzuschlagen im artikel 87a des
grundgesetzes also in der wehrverfassung
dieses grund dieses sondervermögen zu
fahren kommt damit wird auch schon über
den standort in der verfassung deutlich
welchem zweck es dient nämlich der
stärkung der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes
und insbesondere zur stärkung unserer
streitkräfte
das soll aber niemanden zu der
fehlannahme veranlassen dass die bündnis
verteidigungsfähigkeit unseres landes
ausschließlich nur durch eine stärkung
der streitkräfte erfolgen könnte diese
bundesregierung
diese bundesregierung fühlt sich nämlich
dem ansatz
vernetzter sicherheit verbunden so sehr
wie auch mit diesem sondervermögen
insbesondere auch die streitkräfte
stärken wissen wir dass eine große
priorität auch bei diplomatie und
internationaler krisenprävention liegen
muss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir führen konstruktive gespräche mit
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion ich bin
dafür dankbar manches öffentliches
störgeräusch hat es gelegentlich gegeben
die tatsächlichen gespräche finden
kollegial und sachorientiert stadt dafür
bin ich dankbar und so kenne ich auch
die kolleginnen und kollegen der
unionsfraktion von vielen anderen
gelegenheiten
eines aber muss ich sagen es handelt
sich hier um eine entscheidung
historischen charakters
möglicherweise wird man dereinst zurück
schaut auf unsere gegenwart
diese richtungsentscheidung im
zusammenhang mit der vom bundeskanzler
angesprochenen zeitenwende und die
einrichtung dieses sondervermögen in
einem historischen zusammenhang mit dem
nato doppelbeschluss nennen und wenn
tatsächlich diese entscheidung einen
solchen charakter hat dann mag ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion einer
gemeinsamen einigung nur teilweise
zustimmt und nicht komplett und
geschlossen
und ich will schießen mit schließen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen einer
bemerkung wir sprechen jetzt hier heute
um die materielle stärkung der bündnis
und verteidigungsfähigkeit und
insbesondere unserer streitkräfte das
allein wird aber nicht reichen
unterziehen wir uns bitte einer
kritischen selbstprüfung ein früherer
bundespräsident sprach in bezug auf
unser verhältnis zu den streitkräften
einmal von freundlichem desinteresse
möglicherweise ist das noch zu nett
gesagt als aktiver währender und
reserveoffizier hat mich mehr als einmal
auf dienststellen mit kameradinnen und
kamera kontakt gehabt die nach
dienstschluss gefragt haben ob sie in
uniform nach hause fahren sollen oder ob
sie zivilkleidung anlegen sollen weil
sie möglicherweise in der straßenbahn
schief angeschaut oder gar schief
angesprochen werden das zeigt es gibt
gegenüber unseren streitkräften und
jenen die unser land verteidigen dienen
in uniform gibt es nicht nur eine
materielle vernachlässigung sondern auch
eine ideelle
vernachlässigung und dementsprechend
müssen wir nicht nur die bundeswehr mit
geld und ein sondervermögen mit einem
sondervermögen stärken sondern wir
müssen den soldatinnen und soldaten auch
die wertschätzung dieser gesellschaft
entgegen
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hat hier gesprochen zum sondervermögen
bundeswehr und wir sehen es auch an der
regierungsbank dass das hier ein nicht
ganz üblicher beschluss ist der nach
einer zweiten beratung gefällt werden
soll das auf zwei minister sind alle
bundesministerinnen und bundesminister
anwesend war präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
heute genau vor zwei monaten war es als
der bundeskanzler
hier im deutschen bundestag angesichts
des ukraine krieges eine zeitenwende
angekündigt hat ein sondervermögen
angekündigt hat mehr investitionen in
die bundeswehr angekündigt hat und daran
appelliert hat dass wir gemeinsam diesen
auftrag annehmen in dieser schwierigen
situation zusammenzustehen und dem
angriffskrieg
russlands den angriffskrieg putin die
stirn zu zeigen seitdem hat sich die
lage in der ukraine
dramatisch verschlechtert
kriegsverbrechen werden begangen
zivilisten gezielt getötet vernichtungs
drohungen ausgesprochen und genau
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
auch in diesen tagen morgen in einer
debatte aber auch heute am rande des
plenums darüber unterhalten ob
deutschland zukünftig noch mehr
unternehmen kann und auch bereit ist im
bereich der waffenlieferungen mehr zu
unternehmen und schwere waffen in die
ukraine zu liefern meine damen und
herren ich hätte mir es nicht vorstellen
können dass es diese generation von
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
ist die über so eine schwere frage wie
die lieferung von schweren waffen und
über die frage von krieg und frieden
mitten in europa
mitentscheidend muss aber es ist unser
gemeinsamer auftrag die
selbstverteidigung der türkenkriege zu
stärken und deswegen will ich an der
stelle auch sagen wir wollen gemeinsam
mit den ampel fraktionen die
entscheidung mittragen das schwere
waffen an die ukraine geliefert werden
das ist unser gemeinsamer auftrag und
für frieden in europa zu sorgen
ich verstehe übrigens leben sagt auch
das ausdrücklich der dies mit großer
skepsis auch begleitet und ich verstehe
auch jeden der auf die frage will man
schwere waffen liefern er mit nein
antworten würde aber ich sage auch sehr
deutlich in dieser frage ist es
notwendig diese schweren waffen zu
liefern und deswegen muss unsere
gemeinsame antwort darauf sein ja wir
sind als deutschland bereit mehr zu
helfen was bisher mehr zu tun und die
ukraine in ihrer selbstverteidigung zu
stärken meine damen und herren
ich darf erinnern dass der
bundeskanzlerin seiner rede am 27
februar uns mit seiner zeitenwende
positiv überrascht hat
damit war eine reihe von erwartungen
auch verbunden die mit
regierungshandeln zu tun haben leider
müssen wir feststellen dass auch heute
der finanzminister sie hinter diesen
erwartungen zurückgeblieben sind die
tatsache und der hinweis darauf dass wir
über viele punkte gemeinsam in
verhandlungen stehen die dürfen doch
nicht als argument sehen dass sie bei
dem gesetz das sie hier vorstellen
wesentliche teile der ankündigung des
kanzlers die wir unterstützen nicht
wiederfinden lässt wir brauchen klarheit
wir brauchen klarheit ob sie bereit sind
diese ankündigung auch umzusetzen der
bundeskanzler sie haben vom
sondervermögen bundeswehr gesprochen sie
haben von rüstungsvorhaben gesprochen da
haben sie uns an ihrer seite dann
erwarten wir aber auch dass genau diese
rüstungsvorhaben im grundgesetz die
nötige antwort finden 100 milliarden
sondervermögen 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
heißt doch nichts anderes als 100
milliarden sondern schulden für die
streitkräfte
und zwar 100 milliarden für aufrüstung
der streitkräfte und sie nichts anderes
meine damen und herren
bundeskanzler sie haben in ihrer rede
auch davon gesprochen dass wir zukünftig
nun jahr für jahr mehr als zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts in unsere
verteidigung investieren werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen was ist denn an
diesem satz eigentlich so
missverständlich dass es der
bundesfinanzminister in seinen
haushaltsplanungen schlichtweg nicht
berücksichtigen kann der
bundesfinanzminister
sie haben heute im bundeskabinett einen
sogenannten ergänzungs haushalt
vorgelegt 40 milliarden zusätzliche
schulden auch in diesem haushalt findet
sich kein nachwuchs des
verteidigungsministeriums es profitiert
nicht von ihren milliarden die sie heute
vorgestellt hat
das zwei prozent ziel findet sich auch
in diesem haushaltsentwurf nicht herr
bundesfinanzminister wenn sie glauben
sie könnten das versprechen des
bundeskanzlers gegenüber der
öffentlichkeit ab sofort das zwei
prozent ziel zu über erfüllen nur
ausschließlich damit einlösen dass sie
100 milliarden neue schulden aufnehmen
und ansonsten den verteidigungshaushalt
inflationsbereinigt reduzieren dann
werden sie uns nicht an ihrer seite
haben
ich sage dass hier auch in richtung der
verteidigungsministerin und der spd
der fraktionsvorsitzende der spd hat
hier vor kurzem in seiner haushaltsrede
davon gesprochen dass man nachfolgenden
generationen nicht vorschreiben will wie
hoch die rüstungsausgaben sein sollen
das wurde öffentlich interpretiert an
eine klare absage an das zwei prozent
ziel ich will sie alle daran erinnern
seitenwände bedeutet keine einmalzahlung
an die bundeswehr sondern ein
dauerauftrag an unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit
und auch diesen hinweis weil wir in der
tat ist kann das bestätigen den guten
gesprächen darüber sind ob man eine
einigung erzielen kann aber das ergebnis
ob es zu einer einigung kommt ist offen
wir haben die punkte die angesprochen
wurden sind bisher noch nicht gelöst wir
haben weitere gespräche an dieser stelle
vereinbart und zu diesen gesprächen
gehört auch dass wir uns über eine
solide haushaltspolitik unterhalten
schulden machen alleine ist noch keine
solide haushaltspolitik der
bundesfinanzminister sie können mit uns
weiter verhandeln über die frage ob 100
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr für
die streitkräfte aufgenommen werden aber
sie müssen auch mit uns darüber reden
wie wir diese 100 milliarden wieder
tilgen schuldentilgung ist ein
grundprinzip solide haushaltspolitik und
auch daran erinnert
alexander dobrindt vorsitzender der csu
landesgruppe hatte unter anderem
kritisiert dass noch nicht klar ist oder
nicht vereinbart wurde im haushaltsplan
wie das zwei prozent ziel der nato
umgesetzt werden soll dieses ziel
wurde 2014 schon in wales von den nato
staaten vereinbart auch damals seitdem
wurde es ihn nicht von deutschland
erreicht
der russische präsident putin hat mit
seinem überfall auf die ukraine die
friedensordnung in europa zertrümmert
gewissheiten und vereinbarungen auf
denen das freie und friedliche leben von
millionen menschen in europa aufgebaut
waren es zerstört und heute kämpfen 40
millionen ukrainer um ihr leben dieses
land kämpft um die existenz und
gefallene und ermordete zeigen uns was
auf dem spiel steht sollte putin diesen
krieg gewinnen
und niemand weiß was dann das nächste
ziel wäre und wer mit menschen an der
ostflanke der nato spricht der kann
spüren welche sorgen da bestehen dass
sie die nächsten wären die überfallen
werden und die dann nicht standhalten
können das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
dazu sind wir aufgefordert sowohl
unseren verbündeten unseren alliierten
beizustehen aber auch dafür zu sorgen
dass wir hier in deutschland sicher
leben können meine damen und herren
auf diesen brutalen angriffs krieg hat
die bundesregierung mit großer
entschlossenheit aber eben auch mit
besonnenheit reagiert und das ist das
gebot der stunde entschlossen aber eben
auch besonnen zu sein damit diese
furchtbare situation die sagt furchtbare
krieg nicht eskaliert das sind wir den
bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses landes
schuldig und wer sich umhört wer sich
ernsthaft um hört der bekommt genau das
gesagt bitte achtet darauf dass dieser
krieg ein dritter weltkrieg wird bitte
sorgt dafür dass es nicht zu einer
eskalation kommt und genauso werden wir
auch in zukunft handeln in der
bundesregierung
auf diese veränderte situation haben wir
durch waffenlieferungen in die ukraine
reagiert aber wir müssen auch hier in
deutschland darauf reagieren und zwar
indem wir unsere eigene wehrhaftigkeit
stärken diese zeitenwende die
mittlerweile international ein begriff
ist sie muss mit leben erfüllt werden
sie darf nicht nur ein begriff sein und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass mit
diesem von olaf scholz vom bundeskanzler
angekündigten sondervermögen endlich
unsere bundeswehr so ausgestattet wird
dass sie ihre aufgabe erfüllen kann die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
auch zu gewährleisten dass es über jahre
hinweg jahre hinweg zusammen gespart
worden sodass inspekteure der bundeswehr
darüber reden dass wir lang sind das mag
zugespitzt seien aber den kern den kern
trifft es und damit muss endlich schluss
sein
diese 100 milliarden dringend gebraucht
und sie werden nicht alleine gebraucht
für aufrüstung herr dobrindt nein sie
dann für andere dinge auch gebraucht
dafür dass ge endlich dafür sorgen
können dass unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten die schutzausrüstung haben die
sie brauchen
gehen sie doch mal hin zu der truppe
sprechen sie doch mal mit soldatinnen
und soldaten
und dann bekommen sie erzählt was was
was alles fehlt deswegen es geht nicht
um aufrüstung es geht auch um ausrüstung
es geht darum dass endlich dieses dieses
geschehen kann langfristige brust
projekte gekauft und angeschafft werden
genauso wie munition und vieles andere
mehr ich will ihnen mal eine einige
beispiele nennen braucht man diese
riesige lücke erkennen kann zwischen dem
was auf dem papier steht der bundeswehr
und dem was wir tatsächlich zur
verfügung haben wir haben zum beispiel
auf dem papier
350 schützenpanzer puma
davon sind tatsächlich
150 einsatzbereit
150 sind nur einsatzbereit war die
entsprechenden möglichkeiten nicht
gegeben sind um sie beispielsweise in
stand zu setzen wenn das erforderlich
ist beim kampfhubschrauber tiger sitzt
nicht anders aus von 51 maschinen können
gerade 9 abhebens und bei der munition
die wir dringend brauchen in unserer
verantwortung in der nato nachkommen zu
müssen müssen 20 milliarden eingesetzt
werden und das ist erforderlich und das
können wir über dieses sondervermögen
gewährleisten und dann werden wir auch
die zwei prozent der nato quote erfüllen
können sie haben völlig recht da wird
einiges aus dem haushalt erfüllt ich
habe aber auch die möglichkeit dringend
notwendige anschaffungen vorzunehmen
über dieses sondervermögen und das geld
das im haushalt vorgesehen ist dann für
die beispielsweise diese ausrüstung
einzusetzen so wie wir es jetzt auch
ganz aktuell gemacht haben und da will
ich recht hat sich danke sagen an
diejenigen die im haushaltsausschuss und
den verteidigungsausschuss so flexibel
waren obwohl wir ja noch immer in einer
vorläufigen haushaltsführung sind dass
es schnell gelungen ist 2,4 milliarden
euro und die hand zu nehmen um diese
schutzausrüstung endlich möglich zu
machen war geplant für 20 31 weil man
nicht das geld zur verfügung hatte 20 31
solange sollten die soldatinnen und
soldaten darauf warten endlich diese
schutzausrüstung zu haben jetzt ist es
gelungen auch weil wir diese perspektive
haben schnell zuzugreifen und schnell
dafür zu sorgen dass das gewährleistet
ist meine damen und herren
diese zeitenwende
die so geredet jetzt so so so zurecht
auch in diesem großen anspruch diese
zeitenwende hat auch dazu geführt dass
wir viel ernsthafter endlich über
militär endlich über verteidigung
endlich über sicherheitsfragen sprechen
diese ernsthaftigkeit genau die brauchen
wir auch wenn es jetzt um das
sondervermögen 100 milliarden geht und
ich bin ihm dankbar dass sie genau diese
ernsthaftigkeit in dieser woche an den
tag legen und dem antrag im gemeinsamen
antrag der ampel koalition jetzt doch
zustimmen genau die ernsthaftigkeit
brauchen wir genau diese ernsthaftigkeit
brauchen wir jetzt auch bei den
beratungen wenn es um das sondervermögen
geht nicht einfach aus parteitaktischen
spielchen zu sagen da dürfen dann nur
fünf oder nur sieben zustimmen ich weiß
doch dass bei ihnen in den reihen der
union fast alle abgeordneten ohne wenn
und aber hinter der bundeswehr stehen
und dann zeigen sie dass auch in dem
sind diese möglichkeit über der
sonderbar so stehen vielen dank
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht war das und auf sie antworten
direkt wird jetzt peter böhringer der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin wir beraten heute einen
heiklen gesetzentwurf derzeit in der
materiellen absicht auflösung des sehr
langjährigen investitionsstaus bei der
bundeswehr begrüßenswert ist wir
unterstützen dieses ziel der aber
haushaltsrechtlich und auch
verfassungsrechtlich bedenklich ist
zunächst wir sind grundsätzlich gegen
sondervermögen weil sie die reguläre
transparente entscheidungsfindung des
bundestages über den haushalt
beeinträchtigen und nun gar noch eine
absicherung über eine
grundgesetzänderung präzedenz los dieses
sondervermögen wird so nicht nur zitat
des finanzministers neben der
schuldenbremse stehen seiner letzten
endes neben dem haushalt die verfassung
wird missbraucht wenn man eine konkrete
budgetzahlen ins grundgesetz schreibt
und so ohne not einen illegitimen
nebenhaushalt begründet so etwas macht
man nicht völlig ungeachtet des ziels
ordentliche ausrüstung der bundeswehr
was die afg seit jahren recht einsam
fordert
ausgerechnet eine linke regierung gegen
etwas tun dass wir zuletzt vor 130
jahren gesehen haben unter bismarck
wurde der militär etat für mehrere jahre
festgeschrieben das sogenannte sap
system und ausgerechnet die ampel will
nun in ähnlicher weise die demokratische
kontrolle einschränken ich sage nicht
abschaffen ich sage einschränken die 100
milliarden bundeswehr mittel gehören
regulär ohne einführung eines
sondervermögens im kernhaushalt
eingestellt und es ist doch gar keine
frage die mehrheit für diese investition
wie wir sie seit jahren fordern wäre
hier im haus problemlos gesichert es
gebe dafür auf lange jahre 80 prozent
mehrheit und zustimmung hier im haus sie
bräuchten keine zu grundgesetz änderung
lassen sie uns also ehrlich sein diese
konstruktion dient ausschließlich der
umgehung der schuldenbremse das
sondervermögen bekommt sogar eine eigene
kreditaufnahme möglichkeit ohne
festgelegte tilgungsfristen jedenfalls
noch nicht und ohne anrechnung auf die
verfassungsrechtlichen
schuldenobergrenzen nur darum geht es
nur darum wurde diese konstruktion
gewählt schon seit 2020 setzt die
regierung die schuldenbremse immer
wieder ausnahmsweise aus und nutzt die
mittel auch noch zweckentfremdet das ist
permanent der rechtsspruch rechtsbruch
den aber irgendwie außer der afg
jemanden stört und auch heute ist wieder
eine zweckentfremdung der mittel
angelegt denn diese dürfen nach dem
gesetzentwurf mit dem namen bundeswehr
sondervermögens gesetz leider nicht nur
zugunsten der bundeswehr sondern auch
für die aufrüstung von nicht näher
definierten partnerstaaten ausgegeben
werden § 2 all das ist überflüssig und
intransparent der kernhaushalt spiegelt
so zunehmend nur noch einen teil der
wirklichkeit die sozialisten und
umverteilen hier im haus werden das
begrüßen denn natürlich regiert sie es
mit verschleierten und ausgelagerten
schulden viel einfacher zu machen sie es
ja auch schon beim klima vor beim esm
und bei den eu schulden programm wegen
der kausalkette von der schuld
monetisierung der ezb zu hoher inflation
ist das aber fatal wir haben bereits
asoziale 7 prozent teuerung die waffen
die dann ab frühestens sommer frühestens
im herbst oder nächstes jahr über
nächstes jahr aus dem sondervermögen
finanziert werden wer denn den ausgang
des ukraine kriegs nicht beeinflussen
die ukraine krieg dient zwar als anlass
für ein umsteuern bei der seit jahren
vernachlässigten ausstattung der
bundeswehr die notwendigkeit dafür ist
jedoch uralt und keine kriegsfolgen
ukraine überhaupt nicht
wer etwas anderes behauptet und eben
doch einen bezug zur kleine herstellt
und das ist ja eben hier reichlich schon
geschehen der liegt nicht nur
haushalterisch falsch frau ministerin
lambrecht und herr dobrindt sie haben
sich ja nach pressemitteilung heutigen
einigt auf schwere waffenlieferungen das
ding ja auch alles ganz ohne
sondervermögen es geht es geht ohne
sondervermögen nicht nur hosen
ätherische lieben sie darum falsch
sondern sie sollten dann auch erklären
dass man die jahrzehntealte deutsche
staatsdoktrin aufgeben will keine waffen
in kriegsgebiete zu liefern das aber
wäre dann für deutschland nicht nur ein
haushalt eric schweitzer sondern
zugleich ein hochgefährlicher weg
herzlichen dank
peter böhringer hier mit seiner kritik
am vorhaben der ampelkoalition 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr auszugeben für die
bundesregierung spricht nun die
außenministerin anna lena berger
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen dass es eine
besondere debatte heute und auch die
finale lösung führt eine besondere
lesung sein nicht nur angesichts dieses
furchtbaren krieges den die vorredner
bereits angesprochen haben nicht nur
weil wir dich jeden tag hier eine
grundgesetz änderung vornehmen sondern
weil viele menschen viele hauptstädte in
europa aber auch darüber hinaus auf uns
schauen bei diesem sondervermögen geht
es eben nicht nur um 100 milliarden hier
bei uns sondern es geht auch um unsere
zukünftige verantwortung in europa und
in unserem gemeinsamen bündnis es geht
um die zukünftige sicherheit von uns die
sicherheit zukünftiger generationen und
die sicherheit unser bündnispartner und
ihrer zukünftigen
generationen denn unsere bündnispartner
haben uns erst ermöglicht hier in
unserem land in den letzten jahrzehnten
in frieden aufzuwachsen
generationen die meinung in
westdeutschland ein ganzes dem
friedensprojekt europa unsere partner
haben in den letzten jahrzehnten viel in
unsere sicherheit investiert dafür sind
wir dankbar und zeitenwende bedeutet
auch dass wir nicht nur dankbar sind
sondern dass wir das in dem moment wo
andere investitionen von uns in ihre
sicherheit brauchen jetzt zurückgeben
und daher ist es für uns wirklich
entscheidend dass wir dieses
sondervermögen eben nicht nur definieren
und eben nicht nur im grundgesetz
definieren für unsere streitkräfte
sondern unsere bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit und genau darauf
schauen viele menschen eben nicht nur in
deutschland sondern in ganz europa ob
wir unser bündnis verantwortung gerecht
werden und ich möchte noch mal
unterstreichen was vorrednerin und
vorredner und so habe ich auch sie
verstanden herr dobrindt gesagt haben
dass es kein moment für parteitaktische
spielchen und wenn wir ehrlich sind und
alle die ehrlich zu sich selbst sein
können hat jede partei jede fraktion
hier ihr päckchen zu tragen
das wichtige ist doch das was man in der
vergangenheit vielleicht nicht erkannt
hat in zukunft richtig zu machen und
zwar gemeinsam und deswegen ist eine
grundgesetzänderung auch eine gemacht
verantwortung wir haben das in diesem
hohen haus schon öfter gemacht damals in
anderen rollen opposition und regierung
zusammen als europa und brauchte in der
eurokrise nicht auf uns alleine zu
schauen als fraktion und als parteien
sondern unsere verantwortung
deutschlands in europa und es freut mich
sehr dass wir
signalisiert bekommen haben dass wir
diesen weg jetzt gemeinsam geben sie
hatten ein paar fragen angesprochen paar
stehen ja auch in der zeitung auf die
ich ergänzend zu dem was meine kollegen
schon gesagt hatten gerne eingehen
möchte der eine punkt ist die frage von
aufrüstung und ausrüstung ich glaube
dass es kein gegensatz sondern das
gehört ganz denkt miteinander zusammen
vor lamprecht die
verteidigungsministerin hat das bereits
angesprochen wenn wir im baltikum sind
dann wissen wir wir müssen in zukunft
mehr tun an der ostflanke aber wenn man
da vor ort ist und dann zugleich hört
man wagt sich das ja vielleicht gar
nicht auszusprechen die soldatinnen und
soldaten auf der tribüne und wissen das
und gehen jeden tag mit dieser
herausforderung um dann können wir eben
nicht einfach nur sagen wir verstärken
jetzt unsere enhance vor ort präsenz in
der battle trug sondern dann brauchen
wir dafür eben auch die ausrüstung und
wenn man dann sieht dass die ozelot sie
wollen ja angesprochen wurden sind in
der battle gut derzeit
verankert sind zugleich aber eben auch
in der btf der nato gemeldet sind da
müssen wir einfach sagen wir können die
dinge nicht zwei mal melden sondern dann
müssen wir mehr in die ausrüstung
eingeben und das gleiche gilt für den
digitalen funk und sie lachen da wenn
man jetzt eine übung macht und wir sind
die lead nation und das ist nicht
verschlüsselt dann haben wir eine riesen
herausforderung und die wird ein
zweistelligen jahren fährt betrag kosten
und deswegen ist es für uns wichtig dass
wir vor allen dingen auch in die
ausrüstungsdefizite der vergangenheit
gemeinsam jetzt investieren
und das gleiche gilt das gleiche gilt
dass wir eben nicht den luxus haben zu
sagen ostflanke oder nato fähigkeiten
oder
internationale einsätze alles gehört in
dieser komplexen welt miteinander
zusammen wir tragen auch weiterhin eine
verantwortung im rahmen der vereinten
nationen peacekeeping und da haben wir
das gleiche problem for lambs
angesprochen 51 tiger kampfhubschrauber
eigentlich könnten wir uns ganz einfach
machen und sagen wenn die franzosen
gehen dann stellen wir kampfhubschrauber
leider funktionieren aber nur neun von
den 51 deswegen ist der weg eben nicht
so einfach und deswegen müssen wir uns
jetzt den kopf zerbrechen wie wir in der
vn mission bleiben können und auch dafür
dient das sondervermögen damit wir in
zukunft unserer internationalen
verantwortung auch dort in den vereinten
nationen gerecht werden können
und es freut mich sehr dass wir hier so
eine ernsthafte debatte führen und danke
auch an die außen- sicherheits-
politiker in der union wir haben ja
schon viel darüber gesprochen weil zeit
für pappkameraden ist es nicht ich
möchte es hier trotzdem noch einmal
sagen weil in der öffentlichkeit ich
manchmal diese argumente hören es geht
bei diesem sondervermögen nicht um
humanitäre hilfe die ist absolut
notwendig dafür stellen wir aber einen
ergänzungs haushalt auf es geht hier um
harte
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im sinne der
vernetzten sicherheit im sinne der nato
anrechenbarkeit von den fähigkeiten die
wir leisten müssen aber sie haben gesagt
warum stehen da nicht die zwei prozent
im gesetzentwurf war dann würden wir sie
auch ins grundgesetz schreiben und
wollen wir jedes jahr wirklich zwei
prozent investieren was es in dem jahr
über die f35 was ist was es in dem jahr
die f35 kaufen da sind es vielleicht
mehr als zwei prozent wollen sie denn
das grundgesetz an diesem tag ändern und
in dem klar wo es danach weniger ist
wollen sie es dann wieder ändern nein
das was wir machen müssen um die nation
unsere verpflichtung gerecht werden
unser nach der verpflichtung gerecht
werden und zugleich mit dem
sondervermögen die lücken zu schließen
die leider in der vergangenheit gerissen
worden sind und ein letzter satz dazu
ein letzter satz dazu warum die debatte
so wichtig ist wir haben auch erlebt es
geht nicht nur um immer mehr geld was
wir sehen warum wir manche lücken haben
ist ein beschaffungswesen und vor allem
ein bewirtschaftungs wesen wo man sich
jetzt fragt warum passt die eine panzer
schraube eigentlich nicht zur anderen
panzer schraube auch das sind dinge die
wir in dieser debatte gemeinsam angehen
müssen dass es hart dass es ernsthaft
aber das ist die verantwortung unserer
zeit für unsere generation für
zukünftige generationen in europa und
zwar nicht nur in deutschland sondern
für alle in europa nord und süd und west
und ost herzlichen dank und ich freue
mich auf die weitere beratung
soweit die
bundesaußenministerium annalena baerbock
hat hier auch nochmal von den staaten
sicherheitspolitischen belangen
gesprochen für die dieses sondervermögen
sein soll auch das fordert die union
dass dieses sondervermögen nicht für
weiche belange ausgegeben wird das wird
die nächste rednerin anders sehen amira
mohammed ali für die linksfraktion
wege der präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen der völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
putins bringt unvorstellbares leid für
die menschen in der ukraine bei uns in
deutschland wächst die angst dass sich
dieser krieg ausweiten könnte die
konsequenz die die bundesregierung aber
aus diesem schrecklichen krieg zieht
nämlich ein sondervermögen in höhe von
100 milliarden euro für das militär
bereitzustellen diese konsequenz ist
absolut falsch
denn das für den krieg in der ukraine
nicht beenden und es wird auch nicht zu
mehr sicherheit für uns führen das
einzige was es führen wird ist dass die
aktienkurse der rüstungskonzerne in die
höhe gehen dass dort die profite steigen
das ist die wahrheit aber kolleginnen
und kollegen diesen irrsinn wenn die als
linke nicht mitmachen
fakt ist
bereits heute gäben die nato stark mehr
als das 17-fache durch militär aus
weißrussland das tut und das hat putin
nicht abgeschreckt er trotzdem diesen
schrecklichen krieg begonnen wie kommt
man darauf dass noch mehr geld fürs
deutsche militär irgendetwas ändern
sollte und russland ist eine atommacht
daran muss ich mal erinnern wer glaubt
das wettrüsten hier zu einer entspannung
der lage beiträgt der ist einfach im
irrtum kolleginnen
noch nie in der geschichte der
menschheit hat ein wettrüsten frieden
und sicherheit gebracht im gegenteil wir
uns man an silvester 83 die älteren
werden sich erinnern da gab es eine
falschmeldung über einen us atomschlag
gegen die udssr
und ein atomkrieg ist nur deswegen
vermieden worden weil er ein
sowjetischer offizier
befehlsverweigerung begangen hat denken
sie mal daran
ist auch schon heute kommt deutschland
jedes jahr mehr und mehr ins militär
aktuell 50 milliarden euro zum vergleich
für familien senioren frauen und jugend
gibt es gerade mal ein viertel davon
nämlich 13 mio und sie behaupten jetzt
die bundeswehr die bräuchten noch mehr
geld um endlich einsatzfähig zu werden
das falsch die bundeswehr ist nicht
wegen zu wenig geld kaum einsatzfähig
sondern wegen des grottenschlechten
managements das ist die wahrheit
ein beispiel
210 millionen euro wurden ausgegeben für
sturmgewehre die im einsatz nicht gerade
aus schießen können und die firma
heckler & koch die musste dafür nicht
mal schadenersatz leisten weil die
kaufverträge so ausgestaltet waren dass
sie dafür nicht haften der kolleginnen
und kollegen wer verhandelt denn solche
verträge und in diese schwarze noch in
diese schwarze noch rund 100 oder
dreifach weitere milliarden steuergelder
versenkt werden nein erklären sie erst
mal wohin die vielen milliarden bisher
geflossen sind herr scholz
mit diesen 100 milliarden euro könnte
man sehr vieles sinnvolles tun dieses
geld würde reichen alle schulen in
deutschland zu sanieren und alle maroden
brücken und schwachen zu modernisierung
und dazu noch alle rentnerinnen und
rentnern ein würdevolles leben im alter
zu ermöglichen
bedeutet die rentenerhöhung armutsfeste
mindestrenten und auch noch zusätzlich
könnte man allen kindern an allen
schulen und kitas jeden tag ein
kostenloses mittagessen zur verfügung
stehen weil das wären mit 100 milliarden
euro möglich aber daran denken ging ich
einmal die versprochene pflege bonus der
ist übrigens auch noch nicht ausgezahlt
worden und ich frage mich wirklich was
ist das eigentlich für eine
verantwortungslose politik klein zu
versprechen werden nicht eingehalten
aber nun sollen 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für flugzeit um waffen
gekauft wurden und panzer mehr gemacht
werden ich finde das wirklich
unglaublich und sie müssen sich
überhaupt
über wunder dass immer mehr menschen
unserem land nicht einmal mehr zur wahl
gehen weil sie jedes vertrauen in
politik verloren haben aber eines eines
kann ich ihnen sagen ja ich kann
verstehen dass sie das sehr ungern hören
ist aber die wahrheit eines möchte ich
ihnen noch sagen wir als linke die
soziale position in diesem land wir
werden ihnen das nicht durchgehen lassen
dankeschön
wir sind aber hier und dann gucken auch
hier sei eine unverschämtheit
amira mohammed ali den zwischenruf
konnten wir nun nicht verstehen aber
wahrscheinlich zählt er darauf ab dass
die linke zwar die fünf prozent hürde
nicht geschafft hat aber durch die
direktmandate die sie erlangt hat ja
auch im bundestag sitzt eine
kurzintervention aus den reihen der
die bundeswehr unsere streitkräfte
ein schwarzes loch genannt ich möchte ja
persönlich erklären ich schäme mich
dafür dass in diesem hause so über
unsere bundeswehr in anwesenheit von
vertretern der bundeswehr gesprochen
wird sie verteidigen das territorium sie
verteidigen das bündnis sie sind kein
schwarzes loch sie sind die garantie für
unsere sicherheit herzlichen dank
marco buschmann ihr bundesjustizminister
ist hier in die reihen der abgeordneten
gegangen um sein recht einer
kurzintervention wahrnehmen zu können
geht es ja herr kollege buschmann das
habe ich nicht gesagt ich habe vom etat
gesprochen und es ist eine tatsache dass
wegen missmanagements das ein grund
warum unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
keine vernünftige ausrüstung haben worum
es nicht genug warme socken gibt finden
sie das respektvoll hier muss man auch
erst mal hinschauen wo das geld
hingeflossen ist und dass sie das geld
nicht kritisiere habe dafür ist zu
metallisierten wollen zu behaupten
sicherlich kein respekt vor der
bundeswehr seien nur unverschämt
genossen die genossen von mir sind in
der bundeswehr hatte mir nicht nachsagen
danke
soweit also die kurzintervention die
bundesjustizminister als abgeordneter
bestellt hat deswegen aus den reihen
seiner fraktion und die erwiderung von
am ihrer mohammed ali es geht weiter in
der debatte mit karsten klein für die
fdp-fraktion er sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die situation
die die ampel am anfang dieser
legislaturperiode bei der bundeswehr vor
gefunden hat war eine situation die von
großen defiziten bei hat mit großen
defiziten behaftet war beim thema
ausstattung ausrüstung motivation und
anerkennung der soldatinnen und soldaten
aber vor allem auch liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der union nach 16 jahren
unions kanzlerschaft beim
abschreckungspotenzial unserer und
streitkräfte und um die aktuellen
internationalen lage und auch gerade die
situation in der ukraine hat diesen
blick noch einmal geschärft auf diese
enormen defizite und wir in der
koalition die ampel hat auch schon erste
schritte eingeleitet um genau diese
defizite abzustellen im gegensatz zu dem
was herr kollege dobrindt hier behauptet
hat haben wir die mittel in dieser
legislaturperiode schon um zehn
milliarden euro angehoben für die
ausrüstung im kernhaushalt der
bundeswehr erste reformschritte sind
auch bei der bundeswehr schon ergriffen
worden und das beschaffungswesen zu
verbessern wir haben zum ersten mal in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland eine bewaffnung für drohnen
auf den weg gebracht und wir haben 2,4
milliarden euro für die vollausstattung
der soldatinnen und soldaten auf den weg
gebracht eine enorme leistung und ein
respektvolles zeichen an unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten dass sie haben
frieden lassen in der letzten
legislaturperiode
kolleginnen und kollegen
und jetzt bringt diese koalition mit dem
sondervermögen mit 100 milliarden euro
einen turbo lift auf dem weg um aus
dieser situation herauszukommen und wir
freien demokraten wir fordern schwere
waffen auch für die ukraine
aber er holt kollege kurdo bringt wer
schwere waffen für die bundeswehr für
die ukraine fordert er muss sie auch der
bundeswehr können viele projekte die
ihre verteidigungsministerien
angekündigt haben zum beispiel die nach
das nachfolgeprojekt zum tornado war
doch niemals durch stifter finanziert im
verteidigungshaushalt das ermöglicht
jetzt diese sondervermögen und deshalb
erwarte ich dass sie zu diesem
sondervermögen zustimmen
in dieser historischen situation liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der union
sollten sie sich ihrer verantwortung
stellen gegenüber der soldatinnen und
soldaten der bundeswehr gegenüber den
menschen in diesem land und gegenüber
den kindern in diesem land denn die
werden irgendwann ihnen mal die frage
stellen wo sie waren wo standen sie in
der situation in dieser historischen
situation wo es darum ging dass wir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundesregierung dieses landes
wiederherstellen können wo waren sie in
dieser situation liebe union und deshalb
die ampel setzt mit dem sondervermögen
die voraussetzung diese
verteidigungsfähigkeit das
abschreckungspotenzial
wiederherzustellen
wir strecken ihnen die hand aus
ergreifen sie diese hand nicht für uns
von der ampel nicht für sie wie ich das
auf einigen reihen von ihnen schon
gehört hat sondern für die menschen für
den frieden und freiheit in europa in
deutschland und auch in der ukraine
vielen dank
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun dr
matthias mittelberg das wort
geschätzte frau präsidentin bei leben
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte mal
das aufgreifen was die beiden
bundesministerinnen hier angesprochen
haben wir haben ja eine sehr ernste
debatte
und wir erleben eine zeitenwende die wir
wahrscheinlich alle nicht so gerne
erlebt hätten und
es ist richtig was der bundeskanzler
gesagt hat vor gut acht wochen hier von
diesem pult frau baerbock hat eben
angesprochen wir müssten uns alle ein
stück weit bewegen aber wenn wir jetzt
mal die letzten die diskussion der
letzten wochen vor dem geistigen auge
passieren lassen und wenn man jetzt die
diskussion um das sondervermögen
verfolgen dann muss ich doch feststellen
dass meine fraktion sich eigentlich am
wenigsten bewegen muss wir liegen
nämlich voll auf der linie des
bundeskanzlers also wenn wir das jetzt
mal ganz ernst sehen
erkenne ich auch sehr an dass sich hier
viele bewegt haben gerade sie frau
baerbock ich sag das jahr anerkennt das
ist alles in ordnung das ist auch
richtig so aber wenn es um die
feststellung geht dann müssen sie vor
allen dingen dafür sorge tragen dass sie
in ihrer eigenen fraktion und der
bundeskanzler muss dafür sorge tragen
dass es in seiner fraktion sich die
leute auf ihn zu bewegen auf seine
position denn da werden seine position
die er vor acht wochen hier
ausgesprochen hat eben gerade nicht
geteilt wird ihnen das gleich noch genau
sagen
so ein foul am 4 das könnte wirklich
witzig frau lambrecht hat hier gesagt
man müsse den begriff zeitenwende jetzt
mit substanz füllen und hat sich an
unsere fraktion gewandt das war jetzt
aber wirklich ein scherz vollem recht
das kann ja gar nie ernst gemeint sagt
das kann nicht ernst gemeint sein also
wenn einer das passt der bundeskanzler
hier vor acht wochen klar und deutlich
angekündigt hat wenn einer das wirklich
zu 100 prozent erfüllen will dann ist
das diese bundestagsfraktion von cdu und
csu aber
wird sie zu 100 prozent
der bundeskanzler hat hier von einem
sondervermögen bundeswehr gesprochen
nicht von einem sondervermögen
sicherheit oder bündnisfähigkeit oder
irgendwas sondern von einem
sondervermögen bundeswehr und deswegen
legen wir wert darauf auch schon was die
formulierung im grundgesetz angeht dass
klargestellt ist dass diese mittel die
wir hierfür extra und außerordentlich
freigeben dass die dann am ende auch bei
unseren streitkräften bei unserer
bundeswehr land und diese stärkung der
bundeswehr ist auch der stärkste und
beste beitrag zur stärkung unserer
bündnisfähigkeit
und ich will ihnen gerne glauben vor
werbung was sie gesagt haben aber es
gibt hier auch andere aussagen von
leuten hier in diesem parlament die
nicht ganz unberechtigt sind
beispielsweise der
spd-fraktionsvorsitzende kollege münze
nicht der hat ihr vor einigen wochen in
der generaldebatte fast das gegenteil
dessen erklärt was der kanzler gesagt
hat es ging nämlich darum hat die
bereiche humanitäre hilfe
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
abrüstung genannt und die sagte er
wortwörtlich wir wollen diese bereiche
genau so gestärkt sehen wie die
investitionen in die bundeswehr
angesichts dessen und angesichts auch
der ankündigung vom kollegen kindler
hier zivile krisenprävention und andere
dinge aus den mitteln zu finanzieren
haben wir manifeste zweifel ob sie
wirklich die mittel zur stärkung der
bundeswehr verwenden wollen und ob sie
die wirklich zu stärken auch der
bündnisfähigkeit verwenden und das sage
ich ganz deutlich und deswegen legen wir
wert auf klare formulierung schon im
grundgesetz das was sie heute hier in
den bundestag eingebracht haben ist so
für uns nicht zustimmungsfähig
und
ich sachen ein letztes
ja ich sage ganz genau so wie es heute
formuliert ist so wie es heute hier
eingebracht ist so wie es jetzt vorliegt
ist es nicht zustimmungsfähig so wir
haben einen weiteren punkt nämlich die 2
prozent von denen der bundeskanzler
ausdrücklich gesprochen hat er hat
ausdrücklich den satz gesagt von von nun
an jahr für jahr mehr als zwei prozent
des bruttoinlandsprodukts in unsere
verteidigung zu investieren klare
aussage des grundes kann da müssen wir
uns kein millimeter auf ihn zu bewegen
da sind wir voll auf der linie des
bundeskanzlers da unterstützen wir ihn
zu 100 prozent klare aussage von herrn
mützenich ich zitiere jetzt auch die spd
ist nach wie vor der auffassung dass zur
kriegs verhinderung mehr gehört als
immer größere rüstungsausgaben und schon
gar nicht gehört dazu nachfolgenden
generationen vorzuschreiben wie hoch
diese ausgaben zu sein haben julio wenn
ich feststelle dass ist das exakte
gegenteil dessen was der bundeskanzler
hier gesagt habe so und wir legen schon
wert darauf
wenn sie es mit der zeitenwende wirklich
ernst meinen dass wir das dann hier auch
gesetzgeberisch exekutieren wir stehen
dafür zur verfügung aber wir stehen
wirklich auch für lösungen zur verfügung
die das umsetzen was der bundeskanzler
hier vor acht wochen gesagt hat
angekündigt hat dazu haben wir haben wir
applaudiert aus überzeugung aber wir
wollen das dann auch konsequent so
umgesetzt wissen nach china
mathias middelberg der stellvertreter
fraktionsvorsitzenden der unionsfraktion
war das hier in der ersten beratung zum
bundeswehr sondervermögen der wird es
einerseits um die änderung des
grundgesetzes und dann auch um den
gesetzentwurf um dieses sondervermögen
einzurichten achim post spricht jetzt
für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
jeder debatte im deutschen bundestag ist
wichtig zweifelsohne aber nicht in jeder
debatte im deutschen bundestag geht es
um grundlegende ja historische
weichenstellung so wie heute und
deswegen sollte man sich sollten sich
alle hier sollten wir alle hier über
das nachdenken über das reden worum es
wirklich geht es geht um ein
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr es
geht darum die bundeswehr zu ertüchtigen
zu verstärken und handlungsfähiger zu
machen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist es wert darüber ganz in ruhe
ganzjähriges ganz ordentlich zu
diskutieren
denn wir wissen doch alle wir wissen
doch alle der krieg in der ukraine ist
ein krieg ging das ukrainische volk
einen krieg gegen die menschlichkeit und
verantwortlich dafür sind nur putin und
seine schergen und sonst niemand über
kolleginnen und kollegen
und wir sind hier einige vorgängerinnen
vornamen angesprochen wir sind hier
einander situation wahrscheinlich die
schwierigste sicherheitspolitische
bedrohungslage für deutschland und für
ganz europa seit 1945 da sollten wir uns
auch in der debatte mal mäßigen und
nicht so tun als wüsste man alles besser
herr mittelberg und hätte alles von
vornherein sagen da würde ich ein
bisschen vorsichtiger sein auch die
riege der verteidigungsministerium
vertreter der cdu drei viertel der
verteidigungsminister in der
bundesrepublik deutschland wird nämlich
ihre partei an also ein bisschen mehr
demut wäre angebracht liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und
und es gibt opfer
putins aggression
putins aggression wild zweierlei ja er
will die ukraine erobern und zwar
komplett aber er will auch die
demokratie beschädigen schwächen kleiner
machen und deshalb liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen bin ich dafür dass wir haltung
zeigen dass wir uns stark machen mit
unseren werten mit unseren überzeugungen
und mit unserem zusammenhalt das ist ja
auch ein wichtiger punkt in einer solch
schwierigen lage liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deshalb lieber kollege und
kollegen sage ich mal 1
ich habe genau zugehört bei dem was der
bundeskanzler gesagt hat übrigens auch
bei dem was mein fraktionsvorsitzender
rolf mützenich gesagt hat vor acht
wochen und auch bei dem was der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu und csu
gesagt haben und ich darf sie zitieren
herr merz sie haben gesagt ja liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das war eine
gute regierungserklärung das ist doch
mal ein satz mit dem kann ich arbeiten
mit dem können wir alle arbeiten die wir
kollegen unterlegen das finde ich dass
man eine sehr
regierungserklärung das war eine sehr
gute regierungserklärung des
bundeskanzlers und deshalb und deshalb
machen sie doch weiter so machen sie
weiter so bei solchen sätzen mit solchen
klaren sätzen und versuchen sie das was
wir versuchen alexander dobrindt hat es
doch versuchen denn so nachrede
natürlich können wir in diesem haus und
natürlich werden wir in diesem haus
darüber reden wie das geld für die
bundeswehr ausgegeben wird sinnvoll
ausgegeben wird und natürlich werden wir
darüber reden wie wir tilgung
organisieren und natürlich werden wir
darüber reden über parlamentarische
kontrolle richtig machen und fertig
organisieren hier in diesem hause und
deshalb zusammengefasst
deshalb sind deshalb zu sagen deshalb
zusammengefasst das angeboten meiner
fraktion an sie ist ganz klar wir
möchten dass sie mitmachen bei einem
überparteilichen
grundkonsens für die sicherheitspolitik
in der bundesrepublik deutschland und
wir haben ein klares angebot auf den
tisch gelegt und deshalb bedanke ich
mich noch mal an dieser stelle war der
bundesregierung beim bundeskanzler bei
christian lindner bei annalena baerbock
und bei christine lambrecht für das was
sie in den letzten wochen nach vorne
gebracht haben bei diesen grundlegenden
sicherheitspolitischen projekt und ganz
am schluss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
cdu csu ganz am schluss muss man sich
entscheiden man muss sich in solchen
debatten entscheiden was man will will
man konstruktiv mitmachen ich nehme den
einen oder anderen war dass er das will
will man konstruktiv mitmachen oder herr
merz wenn man bei dem bleiben was ich
beim letzten mal gesagt haben als sie
nicht da haben sie müssen sich
entscheiden was sie wollen staatstheater
oder staatsräson
soweit adrian hass auf ihn folgt nun
michael espendiller für die fdp-fraktion
er sitzt im haushaltsausschuss für die
afg fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube ich habe neulich eine
sehr treffende kurzanalyse über unser
land gelesen darin hieß es deutschland
dem wahrnehmung seiner sicherheits
interesse an die nato outsourced seine
produktion in china und seine
energiegewinnung an russland und
natürlich ist das jetzt etwas
vereinfacht dargestellt aber es trifft
doch ziemlich ins schwarze denn unser
land ist in existenziellen fragen von
anderen nationen abhängig insofern
begrüßen wir dass diese bundesregierung
jetzt endlich aufgewacht ist und
begreift wie dringend notwendig eine
adäquat ausgestattete bundeswehr für die
sicherheit und souveränität unseres
landes ist den eingeschlagenen weg
hierfür 100 milliarden euro neue
schulden zu machen und nicht endlich
einmal den rotstift bei der
ausgabenpolitik anzusetzen kritisieren
wie allerdings deutlich sie hätten auch
einfach den veritas dauerhaft erhöhen
können das wäre haushalterisch sauber
und den bürgern gegenüber ehrlicher
insofern
insofern kann ich den ausführungen eines
kollegen peter böhringer umfänglich
zustimmen was ist darüber aus noch
beschäftigt ist natürlich das
beschaffungswesen egal ob sturmgewehre
transporthubschrauber tankschiffe oder
die noble restaurierung der gorch fock
in der deutschen öffentlichkeit herrscht
die meinung vor dass die bundeswehr in
sachen beschaffung ein fass ohne boden
ist und das steuergeld auf
nimmerwiedersehen verschwindet und der
kollege buschmann bevor sie sich dann
wieder aufregend es ist hier steuergeld
das ist nicht unser gipfel müsse auf
jeden euro achten eine reform des
beschaffungswesens daher dringend
erforderlich
das haben wir die letzte legislatur
immer wieder angemahnt und diese
forderung erhalten wir auch nach wie vor
aufrecht allerdings muss der ehrlichkeit
halber auch gesagt werden neben dem
beschaffungswesen waren ist auch immer
wieder unterschiedliche zielkonflikte
die militärische beschaffungs projekte
belastet haben und einer der größten
zeichnet sich auch jetzt wieder beim
sondervermögen an es ist absolut
nachvollziehbar dass die bundesregierung
angesichts der aktuellen bagger auf
markt verfügbare fertige produkte setzt
und die bundeswehr schnellstmöglich
kreisstadt fähig zu machen doch das
bedeutet aktuell dass deutschland im
bereich der größten rüstungsvorhaben
vornehmlich auf produkte aus übersee
sitzt beispielsweise der tonagel
nachfolger soll die amerikanische f 35
von lockheed martin werden und nach
aktuellen berichten will die
bundesregierung auf 60 china
hubschrauber der amerikanischen firma
boeing kaufen der euro fällt weiter von
dem auch ein paar wenige auf dem
einkaufsliste stehen wird immerhin noch
in deutschland gebaut doch das kann
nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen dass beim
sondervermögen die standortpolitik und
das bekenntnis zur deutschen wirtschaft
gar keine rolle spielt nochmals auch wir
sehen die notwendigkeit eines
konsequenten handelns bei der ausrüstung
der bundeswehr klar und deutlich was
muss auch gesagt werden dass wir uns mit
dem von der regierung ins auge gefasste
projekte in neue abhängigkeiten begeben
und uns damit finanziell auf jahrzehnte
hinaus festlegen wir befürchten dass es
mit dem sondervermögen zu einem weiteren
verlust wert technischer fähigkeiten in
deutschland kommt und damit auch zu
einem weiteren verlust von
arbeitsplätzen und schlussendlich auch
von deutscher souveränität der
bundestagsfraktion wird das gütesiegel
made in germany und die souveränität
dieses landes erhalten und dafür werden
wir uns in den beratungen bei einsätzen
danke die aufmerksamkeit
die beiden gesetzentwürfe werden nach
dieser debatte an die entsprechenden
ausschüsse überwiesen und der
haushaltsausschüsse wird diese
federführend beraten und so ist auch der
nächste redner hier ein
haushaltspolitiker sven christian
kindler von bündnis 90 den kunden meine
damen und herren die welt ist seit dem
schrecklichen an gastritis lanz auf die
ukraine eine andere damit wurden drei
jahrzehnte europäische friedens
sicherheitsarchitektur aufgekündigt und
zwar einseitig durch die brutale
invasion von wladimir putin und deswegen
stellen sich für uns jetzt in
deutschland viele sicherheitspolitische
außenpolitische fragen neu für mich
unsere fraktion natürlich müssen wir
auch klären welche aufgaben welche
funktionen welche möglichkeiten die
bundeswehr jetzt und in zukunft auch
haben und deswegen ist unsere fraktion
auch sehr klar wir brauchen in diesen
zeiten eine gut ausgestattete bunten
bundeswehr und wir brauchen diesen
zeiten einen stärken unser bündnis oder
verteidigungsfähigkeit genau dafür dient
diese sondervermögen
[Applaus]
und klar ist das natürlich
sicherheitspolitik in diesen zeiten auch
eine vernetzte sicherheitspolitik sein
muss und diesen sicherheitsbegriff hat
auch nicht diese neue regierung auf
gründen das war schon auch ein
sicherheitsbegriff ihn auch die alte
regierung unter kanzlerin merkel
verfolgt hat den übrigens auch die nato
verfolgt denn es war schon immer so das
nato ausgaben eingerechnet wurden die
natürliche streitkräfte betreffen aber
auch darüber hinaus das machen sehr
viele länder der nato auch genau so und
deswegen ist auch nicht sinnvoll ist
werden leben gerade viele cyber-angriffe
auf deutschland auf windenergieanlagen
auf kritische infrastrukturen natürlich
ist klar die abwehr gegen cyber
sicherheit ist in unserem
sicherheitsinteresse und daran müssen
wir investieren
und die außenminister das angesprochen
natürlich brauchen wir auch eine moderne
digitalfunk in deutschland bei der
bundeswehr wochen moderne
verschlüsselungstechnik für unsere
sicherheitsinstitutionen
die ertüchtigung von partner starten wie
die waffenlieferung zum beispiel auch an
ihm kleine sind werden geliefert nicht
aus dem etat des bundeswehr sind aber
natürlich anrechenbaren der rahmen der
nato an quote und dieses bundeswehr die
sondervermögen für bündnisse
verteidigungsfähigkeit sollen eben die
ausgaben die unter die nase gefallen
auch mit einbeziehen und ich will noch
mal sagen auch zur union zu einem
mittelberg krisenprävention
stabilisierung und friedensförderung vom
auswärtigen amt umformen
bundesentwicklungsministerium waren auch
in der regierung merkel schon an
rechnungs fähigkeit und der nato foto
grund wurden auch von der regierung
merkel auch brüste an die nato gemeldet
und ich verstehe nicht wie das jetzt
hier in frage stellen
und ich würde mir einfach wünschen wenn
ich mir die verteidigungsminister
minister der letzten jahre anschaut
franz josef jung karl theodor zu
guttenberg thomas de maizière ursula von
der leyen und annegret kramp-karrenbauer
das waren die verteidigungsministerium
minister der letzten 16 jahre der
bundeswehr etats in dieser zeit
erheblich auch gestiegen und 2014 32
milliarden auf jetzt 50 milliarden euro
und die bundesverteidigungsminister
beschrieben welche bescheidenen zum teil
desolate lage die ausrüstung und
ausstattung der bundeswehr ist so
bescheiden dass er ganz wenig laufen
jetzt aus den beständen der bundeswehr
auch geliefert werden können da würde
ich mir schon wünschen wenn sie hier
sagen mit dem berg wir sind die einzige
fraktion die sich bei diesem verfahren
nicht bewegen soll ich würde mir mehr
demut immer selbstreflexion wünschen
wenn wir auf die letzten 16 jahre
verteidigungspolitik
denn worum es jetzt ja auch gehen muss
ist dass wir nicht über symbolischen
abstrakte quoten diskutieren sondern
darüber reden wie wir diese 100
milliarden euro sehr viel geld sind wie
wir die im sinnvoll ausgeben und
deswegen gab es hier auch keine
schnellschüsse geben sind wir brauchen
sehr konkrete entscheidung welche
fähigkeiten braucht die bundeswehr wer
soll das machen abstimmungen und
europäischen partnern abstimmen mit dem
bündnispartner in der nato nun ist auch
klar sein was macht deutschland was
machen andere partner das muss sehr gut
abgestimmt sein und am besten macht man
das in gemeinsamen projekten und davon
brauchen nach am besten ein
beschaffungswesen wie es in den letzten
16 jahren eben nicht wahr beim
beschaffungswesen einem dafür nicht
führt dass wir sinnvoll geld einsetzen
aber nicht nach dividenden der
rüstungsindustrie erhöhen das kann ich
das hier bei diesen sondervermögen sein
und deswegen sind wir dafür das ist
komplexer und große beschaffungs
projekte darüber finanziert werden dass
wir aber auch das was ja schon gewonnen
wurde bei der bundeswehr mit der task
force auch weiterführen das können erste
schritte seien es noch lange nicht am
ende das schaffen gewesen bei der
bundeswehr neu aufzustellen und dann
wenn du wirklich sinnvolle beschaffungs
projekte organisiert werden und die
konkrete frage ist ja jetzt auch und
union und wir begrüßen es sehr dass sie
sich jetzt ein gemeinsamer antrag der
ampere anschluss wir morgen sehr starkes
gemeinsames signal auch in deutschland
europa und die welt senden dass wir
gemeinsam diesen kleinen humanitär
finanziell aber auch mit
waffenlieferungen unterstützen und die
frage an die ist
und ich wünsche mir sehr dass in den
nächsten wochen wie er in gemeinsamen
gesprächen auch dazu kommen bei den
sondervermögen zu einer gemeinsamen
lösung zu kommen das kabinett hat dafür
einen guten beschluss vorgelegt die
frage ist eben jetzt wollen sie hier in
die verantwortung gehen oder wird nach
parteitaktik bestimmen diese
entscheidung müssen sie treffen wir sind
zu gesprächen bereit vielen dank
sven christian kindler hat hier noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich über
die projekte diskutiert werden muss die
finanziert werden sollen die 100
milliarden euro werden auch nicht in
diesem jahr als gesamtsumme aufgenommen
sondern über die kommenden jahre dann
immer wenn projekte finanziert werden
johann wadephul jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
damen und herren die unionsfraktion ist
das hat sie von anfang an gesagt in der
ersten debatte vor zwei monaten zu
konstruktiven gesprächen
über die von ihnen geplante
verfassungsänderung bereit und diese
bereitschaft besteht fort auch wenn die
heutige debatte eine einigung
schwieriger gemacht hat und das will ich
ihnen kurz erläutern wir müssen erst mal
sozusagen die sache von dem kopf auf die
füße stellen wenn sie wenn wir gemeinsam
der auffassung sind oder sie
insbesondere als regierungskoalition der
auffassung sind dass die bundeswehr mehr
geld benötigt dann haben sie das
haushaltsrecht ja mal die mehrheit in
diesem haushalt sie haben einen
bundeskanzler dann verabschieden sie ein
bundeshaushalt mit ihrer mehrheit der
die bundeswehr
reichend ausstattet es ist ihre
koalition es ist ihre mehrheit
haben sie jederzeit die möglichkeit dazu
wir sehen das nicht im haushalt aber wir
sehen dass nirgendwo sie haben sich
entschlossen gemeinsam zu regieren alles
in ordnung wir sind in der opposition
wir kontrollieren das wie das aufgabe
der opposition ist aber sie haben
offensichtlich dazu nicht die
hinreichende kraft
und jetzt ja das will ich noch mal sagen
wenn das hier losgeht staatsraison
staatstheater da bin ich ja schon fast
bei vaterlandslose gesellen wenn sie
jetzt hier eine regelung aufstellen
wollen dass wir in jedem falle hier
zuzustimmen haben das ist nicht unsere
verantwortung wir bieten seit acht
wochen gespräche über die bundeswehr an
über das beschaffungswesen über das was
sie anschaffen wollen über einen
tilgungsplan über eine formulierung im
deutschen grundgesetz kein einziges
gespräch hat mit mir als
verteidigungspolitiker hier
stattgefunden es hat heute ein zweites
gespräch gegeben es sind acht wochen
vergangen und wir lassen uns nicht mit
diesen markigen sprüchen unter druck
setzen meine lieben kollegen und
verleger kollege war
und zum thema
es ist völlig klar dass die cdu csu
fraktion dass auch meine partei
eine verantwortung hat für den zustand
der bundeswehr das ist vollkommen klar
wir haben ja natürlich die abend 16
jahre dieses land regiert und wenn sie
den äußerungen eines
fraktionsvorsitzenden letzten tagen mal
zugehört haben mit einem rückblick auch
zur verteidigungs und außenpolitik die
auch unser unter unserer verantwortung
geschehen ist dann ist da an
selbstkritik nicht
an selbstkritik nicht gemangelt und das
teilt meine fraktion friedrich merz hat
dazu richtige worte gefunden und wir
müssen das wir schauen uns das mit
selbstkritik an aber hier stehen herr
kollege tor so viele glashäuser um da
würde jeder gärtnereibetrieb vorüber
sein wir stehen sie sitzen auch in einem
glashaus
2009 bis 2013 haben wir gemeinsam
miteinander regiert und herr fricke hat
von uns verlangt dass getötet
gemeinsam haben wir am stärksten gekürzt
bei der bundeswehr wir gemeinsam und die
fdp-fraktion
konzipiert das hat keinen anlass hier
irgendwie den eindruck erweckt dass die
fdp nicht eine mitverantwortung hat
und ich muss sagen
die grüne fraktion hat ein ums andere
mal in der vergangenen legislaturperiode
klipp und klar gesagt dass zwei prozent
nie geht dass das eine und einer völlig
unverantwortliche festlegung gewesen ist
dass die grünen niemals zwei prozent
mittragen können und jetzt können wir
nicht schnell genug ihrer
verfassungsänderung mitteilen sie sitzen
auch im glashaus liebe grün seien sie
daneben
demütig und
was wirklich und das muss ich sagen in
aller freundschaft auch kollege post
aber insbesondere frau
verteidigungsministerin
dass sie uns jetzt hier vorbeten wie der
zustand der bundeswehr ist schlägt dem
fass den boden aus schlägt dem fass den
boden aus ich habe in der letzten
legislaturperiode wie hier jeder weiß
das selbe amt bekleidet und mal um mal
war den haushaltsberatungen darum
gerungen dass wir mehr geld für die
bundeswehr bekommen im grunde mit ihren
worten und wer hat es verändert die
spd-finanzminister scholz hat eine
erhöhung nicht mitgetragen und die spd
fraktion hat sich gegen zwei prozent
gewann in diesem haus das ist ihre
verantwortung
und deswegen sage ich ihnen
hier haben alle anlass auch das selbst
kritisch zu betrachten
nein entschuldigung dass wir sind wenn
wenn im ist doch ganz einfach wenn im
grundgesetz drinsteht dass das geld
wieder bundeskanzlers gesagt hat der hat
nicht von einem erweiterten
sicherheitsbegriff der richtig ist ein
kind ist doch vollkommen klar gesprochen
wird vom bundeswehr vermögen gesprochen
da der kollege mittelberg vorkommt wenn
im wenn drinsteht dass das für die
streitkräfte ist wenn es einen
tilgungsplan geht wenn es das gibt was
finanzminister lindner zu recht gesagt
hat eine reform des beschaffungswesens
und wenn es eine einbindung der union
bei der verwendung der mittel das haben
wir von anfang an gesagt es gibt keinen
platten scheck wenn diese bedingungen
mit uns endlich mal besprochen werden
dann wird man darüber am ende reden
können aber hier sozusagen eine
kommandoaktion zu machen uns in der
sache nicht zu beteiligen und am ende zu
sagen wir sind sozusagen
machen uhr staatstheater und würden der
staatsraison nicht gerecht werden das
werden wir nicht mitmachen so ist es und
danach soll
johann wadephul hier mit deutlicher
kritik an den
ampelkoalition ihren und es gibt eine
kurzintervention aus den reihen der
grünen
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geschätzter kollege wadephul dass sie
meine frage nicht zugelassen haben was
ihr gutes recht ist versuche ich es mit
einer kurzintervention
ich schätze sie sehr das wissen sie auch
und wir kennen uns lange aus der
zusammenarbeit der letzten jahre im
parlament
ich möchte einen rat geben die fraktion
der union
nicht auf eine parteitaktische position
festzulegen
und ihre argumentation zu beginn zu
beginn ihrer rede herr bargeld ihre
argumentation war die sie sind jetzt in
der regierung
wir sind in der opposition
wenn sie glauben dass mehr geld für die
bundeswehr gebraucht wird stellen sie es
doch in den haushalt ein
und ich frage mich
wo ist die ernsthaftigkeit der lage wo
ist die ernsthaftigkeit der situation
sie können doch nicht ernsthaft mit uns
gemeinsam sagen wir sind seit dem 24
zwei dem angriffskrieg von putin auf die
ukraine mit allem was da dran hängt die
furchtbare situation
die gräueltaten die kriegsverbrechen
die tatsache dass die ukraine angewiesen
ist auf unterstützung
humanitär wirtschaftlich und
militärische mittel
und wir wissen wie desaströs die
ausstattung der bundeswehr ist und wir
wissen dass sie 16 jahre
die bundesminister der verteidigung
gestellt haben dann können sie sich doch
an diesem pult nicht einen so schlanken
fuß machen und sagen sie sind regierung
wir sind opposition
regel sie die frage der sicherheits und
friedensordnung die frage der
sicherheitsstandards und unserer
gemeinsamen verteidigungs und
bündnisfähigkeit alleine da habe ich und
sicher viele menschen dem land eine
andere erwartung an die union
kollege war die schulkollegen war die
schule ich bitte noch einen moment um
geduld
ich bin im moment um geduld ich habe
jetzt entschieden dass ich zwei
kurzinterventionen zulassungen sie dann
natürlich auch die doppelte zeit haben
zur erwiderung
das wort hat der kollege fricke zu einer
kurzintervention
kollege wartet wohl da ich wenig von dem
spruch halte suche nach dem schuldigen
das ist so typisch deutsch sondern ich
glaube im parlament muss man nach
lösungen suchen will ich zwei dinge fest
sein erstens sie haben mich richtig
zitiert weil ich ja nun lange schon
haushalt mache und ich deswegen auch
sagen das ist so an der stelle so sind
die zahlen und so sind die fakten und
jeder der hier im raum ist kann sich ja
mal fragen wie ihr abgestimmtes zweitens
ich möchte sie darauf hinweisen ich weiß
nicht ob sie in den gang ist oder ob das
im teil der rede so war der
finanzminister hat ausdrücklich gesagt
was in den letzten 15 jahren war er hat
ganz bewusst nicht gesagt was seit 2013
jetzt passiert ist um auch hier nochmal
deutlich zu machen wo meine fraktion hin
will nämlich in dieser wichtigen zeit
dort wo wir eben keine
zweidrittelmehrheit haben zu einem
gemeinsamen ergebnis zu einer
gemeinsamen lösung zu kommen deswegen
zweitens habe ich eine bitte um antwort
wenn sie sagen mit ihnen hat niemand
gesprochen okay dann müssen wir gucken
dass wir sprechen ich habe auch ich
freue mich auch wenn ich mit meinem
kollegen haase haushaltspolitischer
sprecher
dann an der stelle spreche für mich ist
nur eines bisher nicht ganz klar gewesen
ich dachte gesprochen wird bei ihnen
alleine auf der ebene des
fraktionsvorsitzenden mit der regierung
wenn ich jetzt von ihnen hören dass sie
sagen nein wir können auch hier im
parlament kleinen details reden dann bin
ich dazu als parlamentarier sicher sind
wir alle auch dazu gerne bereit ich
hatte es bisher anders verstanden das
mag ja ein irrtum meinerseits sein das
sage ich ganz deutlich und wenn ich den
fraktions 14 sehe dann höre ich jetzt
das wäre ja auch an anderen stellen
gerne da auch verhandeln können dann
kommt aber etwas zweites dazu und das
will ich dann auch deutlich sagen wenn
wir parlamentarier versuchen mehrheiten
zu finden und ich verhandle jetzt mit
ihnen oder mit meinem konto auf
haushalts ebene verhandelt ich dann mit
der gesamten fraktion da hätte ich gerne
andere antwort oder verhandelt ich nur
mit dem teil der den teil ersetzt wie
wir es vom fraktionsvorsitz gehört haben
wir erreicht um die mehrheiten zu
erreichen wenn dann möchte ich mit der
gesamten cdu csu fraktion ein ergebnis
haben ein kompromiss der im endeffekt
heißt ein gegenseitiges nachgeben
entsprechend von kräften
kräfteverhältnissen und vernunft danke
sie zwei
kurzinterventionen
johann wadephul antwortet
schwieriger machen ich empfehle ihnen
herr kollege fricke mit dem
finanzminister
entsprechende gespräche zu führen es
geht ja nicht um weniger als darum ein
dass die verfassung zu ändern und hier
werden jetzt gespräche geführt die sind
ja auch richtig sie sind auch vereinbart
zwischen dem finanzminister und seinem
staatssekretär und zwei vertretern aus
unserer fraktion aber es geht darum eine
verfassungsänderung zu machen die weite
teile der bundeswehr in der
verteidigungspolitik umfasst und
deswegen fände ich ist eine gute kultur
dass wir breit angelegte gespräche
führen die alle fachbereiche mit
einbezogen werden die davon betroffen
sind das sind rechtspolitiker das sind
verteidigungspolitiker und das ist
bisher nicht geschehen da sind da sage
ich nur da sind acht wochen jetzt
verstrich nur das ist ruhezeit wenn wir
vor der sommerpause die sache
verabschieden wollen dass das in einer
breite und in einer tiefe geschickt so
dass die fraktion in einer gesamtheit
sich eine meinung bilden kann und einer
möglichen verfassungsänderung zustimmen
kann das ist bisher nicht geschehen da
sollten sie sich bei 1 lindner noch mal
informieren und frau kollegin hasselmann
ich will dass wir noch mal
in aller ruhe so sagen bei gegenseitiger
wertschätzung die wirklich auch
weiterhin besteht es ist nicht der
normalfall dass für die finanzierung
eines wesentlichen teils des staates
nämlich ihre seiner streitkräfte die
verfassung geändert wird und ein
sondervermögen ehrlich gesagt ja sonder
schulden aufgenommen werden das ist
nicht der normalfall dass wollen sie
doch wohl nicht bestreiten oder wollen
sie uns jetzt bei jeder gelegenheit hier
auffordern die verfassung zu ändern
damit sie die notwendigen mittel haben
um dann ihre politik einfach gesetzlich
mit mit ihrer ampel mehrheit umzusetzen
das wollen sie doch nicht ernsthaft hier
behaupten und deswegen wiederhole ich
einfach in der sache die punkte über die
uneinigkeit besteht die
verfassungsänderung die sie uns vom text
her jetzt vorschlagen entspricht nicht
dem vorschlag den der herr bundeskanzler
gemacht hat das ist für die bundeswehr
ist das ist mal der erste punkt der
zweite punkt ist der bundeskanzler hat
vollkommen zu recht gesagt dass zwei
prozent ab jetzt und dauerhaft
eingehalten sind das sehen wir weder im
jetzigen haushalt noch in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung der
bundesregierung sondern da sehen wir ein
einfrieren des einzel planes 14 der für
die bundeswehr vorgesehen ist auf gut 50
milliarden euro das ist lichtjahre von
zwei prozent entfernt und deswegen sage
ich schon die beiden punkte sind schon
nicht erfüllter deswegen stimmt das was
mathias middelberg gesagt hat die cdu
csu fraktion ist sofort in der lage die
vorschläge des bundeskanzlers aus seiner
rede vom 27 februar eins zu eins
umzusetzen sie nicht und das ist der
unterschied
soweit die erwiderung auf zwei
kurzinterventionen und damit kommen wir
zum nächsten redner in dieser debatte
wolfgang hellmich ist das für die spd
fraktion ist der verteidigungspolitische
sprecher der sozialdemokraten hier im
deutschen bundestag
braucht präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen die sachen liegen auf den
tischen sind ausgetauscht was macht man
in einer solchen situation sprechen
miteinander und ich glaube die debatte
darum wie man miteinander spricht und
wärmen man da spricht können wir an
dieser stelle auch gar nicht fortsetzen
sondern es wird die frage der handel nun
sein die an auf bach haben zu sprechen
ich habe am letzten wochenende etwas
länger mit einer 96-jährigen mutter
gesprochen
das war mal dringen nötig ja aber sie
sagte mir sie hat angst
und ich glaube das was sie mir an angst
ausgewirkt hat mit einer ganz anderen
historischen erfahrung als viele in
dieser gesellschaft war nicht nur sehr
ernst gemeint sie war tief getroffen und
sie haben gesagt ihr die in der politik
seit ist es eure auftrag des eure
verantwortung für mich hier zu sorgen
damit ich weiter in sicherheit leben
kann und das ist die messlatte für das
was wir tun die mistel hatte die
erwartung von vielen menschen in dieser
gesellschaft in ganz europa und darüber
hinaus der der entgegenzukommen die auch
zu bedienen zu sagen wir sind in der tat
voller verantwortung dafür diese
sicherheit auch zugang zitieren sie hat
mir auch gesagt ich vertraue den
bundeskanzler
weil er mit ruhe und bedacht an diese
fragen angeht und kann flügelschlagen
keine lauten töne anspricht sondern klar
und verlässlich mit der situation die so
ernst ist wie sie nie war so weit sei
das erlebt hat nie wagen auch damit
umgehen und 1000 probleme zu lösen und
das mit demjenigen
wie an dieser in dieser situation an
unserer seite stehen auch das war eine
erfahrung die sie mir meter gegeben hat
nämlich mit denjenigen die schon immer
einmal für unsere sicherheit besorgte
auch in diesem bündnis klar dafür zu
sorgen dass es frieden in diesem europa
in dieser welt gibt das ist die
herausforderung
das ist das ziel das man sich setzen
muss und zu diesem ziel dieses ziel zu
erreichen gehören und dazu bin ich fest
überzeugt in einer werft demokratien an
den werften land in einer werft in
europa ihren werten bündnis werte
streitkräfte und er sah bin ich er habe
ich neue erwartungen daran dass wir mit
diesem 100 milliarden programm genau
dieses ziel wehrhafte streitkräfte zu
haben auch erreichen kann
wir kommen ja nun mal als
verteidigungspolitiker immer wieder mehr
aus dem maschinenraum
aus dem maschinenraum des konkreten tun
uns dann konkret machen sondern wissen
wo die defizite sind sehr konkret
einsam beispiel hier auch genannt
wenn ein wenig führungsfähigkeit der
mängel daran hat und letztendlich
digitalisiert ins feld ziehen soll dann
brauch aus die nötige ausstattung dazu
gehören aber nicht nur funkel
dazu werden in der nächsten zeit auch
die satelliten gehören wir sicherstellen
dass wir sicher kommunizieren können da
will ich bei cyber sicherheit und die
ist nicht nur fragen gesamten
gesellschaft sondern auch die frage
funktionsfähiger streitkräfte und ich
könnte viele dieser punkte fortsetzen
viele sind auch dabei genannt was
letztendlich angepackt werden mussten
das ziel einen handlungsfähigen
bundeswehr in einem bündnis zu erreichen
einsatzfähig zu sein und dieses bündnis
verpflichten nicht nur nachzukommen in
gegenseitiger verantwortung sondern noch
klar und deutlich zu machen wir stehen
dafür mit einer haltung und nicht nur
mit ankündigung sondern mit einer
haltung des punkt zu wollen und
umzusetzen so wollt was in dieser zeit
notwendig ist und deshalb man herzliche
bitte an der stelle orientieren daran
also ganz persönlich dass ich irgendwann
mal eine mutter wieder besuchen kann dir
sagen kann wir haben dafür gesorgt dass
du zukünftig sicher leben kannst vielen
dank
und wolfgang hellmich war das für die
spd-fraktion und wir kommen langsam zum
ende in dieser debatte zwei redner
stehen noch auf der rednerliste als
nächstes spricht johannes huber erst
mittlerweile fraktionslos
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
mitbürger putin hat in seinem
vertragsentwürfen über
sicherheitsgarantien im dezember 20 21
ultimativ ein ende der nato truppen in
den vierzehn mitgliedstaaten gefordert
in osteuropa das gilt bis heute und
bedroht wie die mittelstrecken raketen
in kaliningrad unmittelbar das
bündnisgebiet das russischen
staatsmedien rt hat am zweiten märz
getwittert dass direkte deutsche
waffenlieferungen den waffenstillstand
von 1945 brechen das klingt wie die
aktuellste aussage von la france der
diese als einen de facto kriegseinsatz
des westens wertet also offensichtlich
russland auch bei deutschland im krieg
sieht russische truppen sind bereits an
der polnischen grenze stationiert die
nicht nur eine quote der über litauen
einnehmen können sondern auch das herz
land europas also polen bedroht und in
der folge die deutsche ostgrenze dass
ein solches szenario real werden kann
zeigte der hybride anderem von
lukaschenko auch die europäische union
mit hilfe der inflations waffe der nur
mühsam dann der polnischen grenze zu
abgewehrt wurde die teilweise selbst
verschuldet der bedrohungslage macht
eine schnellstmögliche materielle
ausrüstung der bundeswehr also
unabdingbar auch die wirklich musste
personell und moralischen
verteidigungsfähigkeit wieder auf die
tagesordnung den bedarf für die
bundeswehrzeit im übrigen die
kriegsführung in der ukraine
es müssen nicht nur die weiter
entwickelten eurofighter und
transporthubschrauber geschafft sondern
für die lufthoheit vor allem der blinde
fleck der mobilen flugabwehr im
nahbereich dass er das mit strenger
bewachten ozelot systemen erhoben werden
auch bewaffnete drohnen sind in der
modernen kriegsführung alternativlos für
die hintendran tating bei der
landesverteidigung gegen eine material
überlegenen gegner braucht es nicht nur
miteinander eingespielt und trainiert
der soldaten plus reserve stn in der
ukraine auch eine widerstandsfähige
zivilbevölkerung eine ministerin die
eigene bevölkerung aber systematisch
entwaffnen will ist angesichts einer
realen äußeren bedrohung ein
sicherheitsrisiko für unser land und ich
möchte schließen mit der
verteidigungsministerin die ebenfalls
unser aller sicherheit gefährdet wenn er
stolz noch da wäre dann könnte ich ihm
sagen und würde ich ihm sagen dass die
verteidigung die er bereits jetzt quasi
vom kanzleramt ausübt dass er sich
selbst damit entlasten könnte aber auch
vor einem konstruktiven
misstrauensvotums sich schützen könnte
wenn er sich jemand als
verteidigungsminister an die seite
stellt die ahnung hat und strategische
und militärische fach kompetenz
mitbringt vielen dank
soweit johannes huber ehemals fdp
fraktionsmitglied mittlerweile
fraktionslos damit kommen wir zum
letzten redner und das ist andreas
schwarz ersetzt für die sozialdemokraten
im haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen kollegen meine damen und
herren am 24.2 hat sich die welt durch
putins angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
verändert olaf scholz hat es richtig mit
dem wort zeitenwende umschrieben an
diesem 27
was hier im parlament nur ein wort in
den letzten wochen wurde dieses wort
aber mit handeln und mit leben erfüllt
von 100 milliarden sondervermögen bis zu
waffenlieferungen
wir erleben eine historische
verantwortung gerade die letzte woche
war auch gezeigt dass diese zeitenwende
unterschiedlich gestaltet werden kann ja
jeder muss das so sein weg finden das
merken auch heute in dieser debatte mit
dieser zeitenwende umzugehen die
regierung muss sich positionieren was
wir klar getan haben die opposition muss
ihren platz finden wo sie gerade dabei
ist und das wichtigste ist wir müssen
die menschen in dem land in diese neue
zeit mitnehmen es gibt da viele sorgen
ja ängste bei den menschen und zu recht
darf ich anmerken es geht um krieg und
frieden die menschen erwarten jetzt von
uns zusammenhalt geschlossenheit und vor
allen dingen ein besonderes vorgehen die
frage ist wie gestalten wir diese
zeitenwende welche zeit nehmen wir uns
für welche maßnahmen die zeitenwende
aber auch gezeigt weil damen und herren
dieses land hat viele militärexperten es
dürfte aber auch klar sein es gibt
beteiligte die haben keine zeit in
dieser zeit mende nämlich unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten
die brauchen schnelle entscheidungen und
darum geht es bei dieser
grundgesetzänderung dafür braucht man
mutige zügige und besonnene beschlüsse
und keine streitereien die frage der
sicherheit unseres landes darf nicht auf
dem altar des parteienstreits oder
wahlkampfes geopfert werden jetzt ist
auch die zeit einen schlussstrich zu
ziehen uns hilft kein blick zurück
sondern es hilft nur der blick nach
vorne natürlich könnte ich jetzt
philosophieren wer ist schuld an dem
zustand der bundeswehr hilft es aber
jetzt sicher nicht dieser krieg meine
damen und herren hat elementare folgen
für die sicherheit in europa und
natürlich müssen und haben wir auch
darauf reagiert mit dem sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden sind wir nun endlich
in der lage die anforderungen zu
erfüllen die die nato an und stellt
klares ziel ist eine leistungsfähige
truppe die die sicherheit unseres landes
gewährleistet und die menschen in
unserem land auch in europa schützt sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass die
anschaffung schnell und unbürokratisch
realisiert werden und das wird schon
eine große aufgabe werden aber es sind
auch hier schon erste entscheidungen
getroffen worden 2,5 milliarden euro
schutzausstattung für unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten die entscheidung bei der
tornado nachfolge um nur zwei zu nennen
dazu gehört aber selbstverständlich auch
eine dringende veränderung im system wir
alle wissen dass die reformen
beschaffungswesen überfällig sind und
ich danke frau ministerin
dass sie schnell tätig geworden ist die
zauberworte die hier viel helfen heißen
anhebungen der nieder schwellenwert
vergabe von 1000 auf 5000 euro schnelle
direktvergaben unter nutzung des
eu-rechts kauf markt verfügbarer
produkte verehrte kolleginnen kollegen
wir schaffen aber auch zusätzliche
sicherheit da das sondervermögen den
kernhaushalten nicht angreift es wird
kein ausspielen das eine gegen das
andere geben das bedeutet im gegenzug
natürlich auch weiter ausreichende
mittel für die bereiche der inneren und
vor allen dingen auch der sozialen
sicherheit zu haben das ist ja das was
unser land auch so stark macht und auch
stark immer durch krisen gebracht hat
mit einem neuen absatz in artikel 87a
thron gesetz kann der bund jetzt mit
eigenem kreditermächtigungen ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
einrichten durch diese verankerung wird
sichergestellt dass diese mittel nicht
für andere zwecke eingesetzt werden
können alle hier im haus sollten sich
dieser verantwortung bewusst seien und
für die grundgesetzänderung stimmen
unsere bevölkerung unser land und vor
allen dingen unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten erwarten dass von uns und auch
hier zurecht dankeschön
soweit also diese erste beratung zum
bundeswehr sondervermögen morgen geht es
hier im bundestag mit unserer
übertragung weiter unter anderem wird es
dort um eine unterstützung für die
ukraine gehen ab 8.45 sind wir dann
wieder für sie aus dem deutschen
bundestag bereit jetzt gebe ich aber ab
zu den kollegen von der tag